tis the season for Holiday pop-up
experiences and the Sand Dollar Lounge
is giving us two yes a miracle on Spring
Mountain and sipping Santa on Main let's
see which one Rocky is live at today hi
Rocky it's looking festive in there
right I know Julian I know you're ready
to move in I know you are but you're
gonna have to share with me because it's
so festive in here so much fun and we
are at sipping Santa on Main okay so
Brian tell us the difference they
mentioned miracle in Spring Mountain and
Sip and Santa what's the difference
between the two experiences
um the original Miracle bar over on uh
Spring Mountain is more of your classic
style of Christmas I mean you have the
lights presents all that sort of stuff
over here we're doing more of a tiki
inspired uh it's called sipping Santa as
well
um and this is just kind of that that
beach Vibe uh you're gonna get all the
Christmas you could possibly handle but
then just attach a little bit of that
kind of tropical Caribbean type of uh
Vibe going on as well I'll take
Christmas on the beach right that sounds
that sounds wonderful yeah let's talk
about the build out because you guys you
know you put a lot of work and time and
money in both of the locations let's
give us some numbers how how decorated
are we
um just to start in order to get into
this whole uh Christmas vibe it's
starting range is thirty thousand
dollars and that is just the very
beginning of it
um and that's if you want to do the
basics obviously if you look around this
is not the basic build out this is not
your basic Decor at all it's a lot of
fun it takes a lot of time a lot of
effort from the staff
um we have a crew that comes in and
helps out with a little bit of the
decorating because this place is so big
and there's just so much to get done
that we really had to you know prepare
well and get this because we can't
really close that long right so exactly
and this location is a little bigger
than the one on Spring Mountain and
before we go I want to talk about the
live entertainment I know you guys are
looking at the drinks we'll talk about
that later but the live entertainment
the stage behind us this is where you
guys really show out for the holidays
yeah and Beyond we're we've always been
known as kind of a local music venue we
support a lot of local artists uh coming
up we've got the hypnotics we have
Lennon roach who's a local artist and
just dropped a new record
um we also have some people from Bad
Moon booking which are a local crew
supporting a lot of that like again
local music town line and giving them
the stage to perform it's really
important to us it's perfect for locals
and tourists alike come down to the Sand
Dollar this is so
Spain you've got miracle and spring
number 31st brand yep December 31st all
right come on down we're gonna talk
drinks and food coming up